So this is all new to me, you know.
To step onto a film set like this is very daunting...
...you know, because it's not my area of expertise.
That probably was the most challenging part for me.
I was nervous but they've been incredible.
They've made me feel very welcomed and I'm very comfortable.
I think I've done okay.
To be able to walk on a set and see Harvey, to see Katherine and then to see Cathy,...
...they've all been part of movies that I've loved over the years,...
...so to actually work with them was a huge honor.
My lasting memories have to be working with a great team.
Everyone on set has been incredible.
Just being here with everyone and being part of this, it's been a great memory.